is there a chart of like time versus
sort of sexualization of anime
I think that like that's probably one of
the tropes that kind of just helps like
one of the cheap shots you can take to
help retain people oh yeah yeah
just don't enjoy it at all in shows I
like hentai I'll watch hentai well you
know separate yeah you know what but you
know what's funny actually the guy who
invented the etchy genre in manga and I
didn't say the guy who invented anime
the guy the guy well basically the guy
who invented like the the kind of
perversion in anime is the same guy who
invented Mecca
so uh they're kind of go hand in hand
yeah I actually believe hideo yakiano
helped popularize the anime boob bounce
it was really literally called like the
gynax jiggle or something the gynax
balance for a while yeah because one I
think it was like one of his earlier
Works what's what's his other Mecca work
that he's done not that's before
Evangelion die Buster die Buster I
believe that had like a famous shot with
like yeah he directed that yeah it's
like 120 frames per second
everyone's like all right is the future
of Animation ladies and gentlemen you've
probably seen the high school the Dead
one as well so that she shoots a gun and
it like I don't think I've seen that one
oh and it goes through looks like her
boobs like jiggling in the gun the
bullet goes between like oh like a gif
or something yeah it's a very famous
but when it's like that it's like okay
now it's so over the top where it's like
it's entertaining again in the middle
ground where you're like why why did you
put this in the [ __ ] like like fire
force like oh yeah yeah that just had
sexualization in it for no [ __ ]
reason I mean there's a lot of shows
that are like that where it's like I
thought I would enjoy the show because
it kind of dealt in genres that I
thought I would enjoy and then it would
just get side shafted by this random
etchy shot I'm just like immature yeah
and like you didn't you didn't need that
you didn't need that to maintain my you
know attention for this show on Netflix
right now in the States they're like
it's like a Mech thing but there's like
a guy and a girl in the Mac right what
is it oh it's only in the frame
[Laughter]
it's like no one's gonna take you
seriously for the rest of the tour okay
I would argue that no one should take
darling in the Frank's side no no one
took it seriously yeah yeah not even the
creators of the show yeah seriously like
it's the moaning though moaning when
they like lock in like
I'm reloading my girl I remember when I
first watched darling in the Franks and
they revealed like the piloting system
in like episode two or three and I just
[ __ ] burst out laughing I'm like no
they did not do this they they didn't
have to though like why okay that's
trigger and they're like yeah they're
just trigger never take them so
seriously it's weird talking to someone
who obviously consumes has consumed like
a lot of old anime versus like I've
consumed I've seen like the progression
of I guess the fan service and
sexualization just kind of like like
having like going from there to there
yeah because it's uh darling in France
was made by Studio trigger and after
killer have you seen or heard of kill
the kill I think so is that like the
talking sure yeah yeah yeah yeah
he made that that darling in the Franks
just felt like it stepped down in terms
of in terms of the fact that we chilled
out yeah yeah yeah yeah which is weird
to say that it kind of like I guess
desensitized a lot of anime fans because
and yet isn't it weird that we are
openly criticizing darling in the Franks
for being sexual but then when you go
over to kill a kill it's like yeah it
depends on the show like Kellyville
never was meant to be serious and
neither was darling in the Franks no
yeah there's other shows where you're
trying to get me invested in this world
and characters in a very serious way and
should it give me to feel like okay oh
I'm so sympathetic to all that character
and then they start groping each other
and then you're like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah what the [ __ ] was that yeah
killer kill was like it made it made a
little bit more sense yeah it did did
you did you ever watch uh seven deadly
sins yeah oh Jesus
it's so unnecessary yeah he'll just
start groping the woman randomly that's
just his personality trait and it's like
oh so this guy's he just molested he's
just a pervert Yeah and that's like his
thing and we're like how he's that's so
funny and quirky he's like no I hate
this guy like how many people you know
actually
we've asked that question yeah many
times
wonders who the [ __ ] watches that
character and likes them people like
that character yeah
yeah because like
there are meliodas stands out there I
mean it's it's a very it was a very
popular anime and manga I don't know how
many people still stand for it fell off
so hard yeah really it was kind of like
fairy tale you know or that kind of
genre of show where it kind of just like
it got it had as a fan base and then it
kind of fell off when everyone started
clowning on it is that in the manga as
well that yeah version yeah yeah so it's
not just the show no no no okay yeah why
would they even add that that'd be even
more
it's kind of boring let's let's just
make him kind of a perv I think that
they would add it in if they weren't
willing to take it out yeah
well they a lot of the time it's it's
while it's not seen as weird to have
that in right and and two I think taking
it out would be just offensive right to
the author in a way it's like how could
you ruin his vision you know also also I
think the reason why Justin I know I
also just think like the reason why in
general I don't think we'll ever see the
The Disappearance I guess of that kind
of like perversion enemies because you
know for horny 14 15 year old boys are
gonna just keep coming yeah I mean they
keep spawning just come on they just
come over and over just keep coming they
just keep coming they keep spawning and
there's there's always going to be an
audience for that kind of [ __ ]
apparently there won't be I mean there's
the population is shrinking so yeah
that's true that's true
today
I mean I mean come on like I remember
when I was a teenager and I first saw an
anime have kind of like this kind of fan
service and right when I was 14 I
thought to love her was like the
greatest thing ever created yeah I know
right and I'm just like that's just like
tits and articles it makes sense and
you're like as a fellow 14 year old I
understand this but then you're like
there's a 40 year old man thinking about
this [ __ ] of me yeah you know yeah he's
like that's true what should I make for
the kids yeah I've got a perversion
never heard anything like yeah I like
this when I was 40. I'm sure the 14 year
olds now would enjoy it like even as
like 20 20 years old 19 I was like
[Music]
I mean that was the age where you're
just like oh I you you discovered that
hentai and PornHub
that was the moment that was the moment
19 and 20. what that was the moment your
brain switches and you're just like I
need more
separation
will not suffice for me I'm trying to
think the first anime I ever watched
like I I feel like I have like this
Pokemon count yeah I mean it's kind of
like that's Japanese I mean that was
like my first one yeah I didn't realize
it was even anime I thought it was yeah
I mean I think that was a lot of our
first anime uh it was either that or
like Dragon Ball Z which is a lot of
people's first anime especially who grew
up in the world
starts watching it you didn't like it
can I say it's crap or people get mad
it's normal yeah
I am very smart okay that's what it felt
like no yeah who was like
the consensus is that it's pretty good I
I thought it was quite intelligent to me
I got through
I don't know maybe like six episodes or
something and I just it just it was like
it just felt like like how old are you
when you found it I feel like because
yeah I feel like if you're under 21 for
some reason no it appeals to that side
yeah I think that's the kind of people
that would be the main character yeah
yeah yeah well I mean that's why I was
in Shonen jump right yeah right yeah
right because for that demographic like
80 year old like 17 year old me ate that
[ __ ] up like yeah I was like of course
I want to be this guy so bad
he gets Death Note dude he was the
original Giga chat bro he he built like
the girls and and the abilities yeah he
was a chat and his dad loved him whoa
that's that's the insane
yeah I mean just thinking
I'm just like thinking like looking at
light now through Modern Eyes I'm like
damn light was a [ __ ] toxic as [ __ ]
person man he was science anime you
watch Doctor Stone no I saw
um oh God what's the time travel one uh
I like that a lot it's nice I mean
that's one of those like Classics I
started watching it years ago I think I
got like one episode in because it's
it's just I feel like every one of these
websites does a bad job like conveying
what it is it's hard to find reviews
that's one of those shows where I think
it's your best shoes click episode I I
stopped watching it though years ago so
I got an episode to be fair the first
stupid or slow or whatever yeah yeah
because I it's almost like there's not a
trustworthy source for me of knowing if
I'm gonna like something to be fair the
first 10 yeah
[Music]
the first 10 episodes are quite slow but
I think it's it's used to just build up
enough information and to get you
established enough where the second half
comes around you're just like oh [ __ ]
yeah it's also great in English the
English version is amazing I I just
watch everything have you watched
Psychopaths no okay
just just judging from what you've been
saying and judging from that's what kind
of shows you like you love Psychopaths
because it is a Sci-Fi doesn't have me
it doesn't have genre unfortunately sell
the viewers on it like picture to them I
think we've done this before but do it
again yeah
do the thing uh I mean it's a Sci-Fi uh
dystopian world that is very reminiscent
of a lot of classic Sci-fi stories uh
the entire world is based on a system
where you control People based on an
emotional score and there are points
where if you go beyond an emotional
score the system deems you as a threat
to society so they will automatically
lock you up or or if you get too
dangerous there's a gun that will shoot
you and you will literally explode right
you're literally too depressed yeah if
you literally get you're literally
disintegrates and what makes it so
interesting
exactly exactly is interesting and what
makes it so interesting is you know they
set up this world and the main villain
is basically someone who is so insane
that he breaks the system by being on a
level of insane that he's almost seen as
in in the system's eyes as the perfect
human being so that's that's that's kind
of like that's that's kind of the main
story of psychopaths
yeah yeah really really interesting and
it delves into some really interesting
ideas about if this Society really
existed what would happen to the people
in it how would they act how would it
how would they you know change and how
could you break a system like this yeah
it tackles moral issues I think really
really well to the point where it's like
it doesn't seem trophy in any way like
it actually gets you being like oh [ __ ]
if this was you know if if I was born in
a situation like this what would I right
I was gonna say it's like situation
based like yeah here is a problem and
then someone has to deal with it yeah
yeah exactly yeah yeah so judging from
now you'd really really enjoy that
because I can't I can't think of like
another modern Sci-Fi show that's hooked
to me as much as Psychopaths has it's oh
what about Buck uh uh bulkarana have you
seen bulkarana oh yeah I love that one
too that's Mecca I always recommend that
one that's Mecca that doesn't have a
whole lot of politics to it yeah and
it's also psychological so you might
like that one as well
we've talked about that a few times like
[ __ ] up this is this is just this is
just what what anime wouldn't really
I [ __ ] up I sat through darling in the
Franks
that's a different kind of fun that's
just that's not [ __ ] up that's just
what the [ __ ] yeah that's the trigger
going let's how can we make everything a
sexual innuendo okay let's let's just
make an entire show
um and just make it and make it like one
big section what happened to like
steering wheels and like joysticks I
thought mama my robots to have hand
control what are you gonna make a robot
that's controlled by a human yeah that's
the next video I don't know what we're
doing tomorrow